but what is a permutation well basically
what a permutation is it's an ordering
okay of a group of objects and we'll
take a look at some examples in a little
bit but first let's take a look at some
formulas here what we have is NPR okay
which is basically out of n items how
many ways can you pick our items okay
where the order is important so the
formula is n factorial over n minus R
factorial where as combinations and CR
out of n total items how many ways can
you choose our items where the order is
not important and I'll show you an
example just a minutes but this formula
is n factorial over N minus R factorial
R factorial okay so take a simple
example like say you have a hat with
three marbles okay in it a B and C and
you just want to find out how many ways
are there to pick two marbles out of the
three at random okay here how many ways
are there to pick two where the order
matters so here what we're going to do
is we're going to do permutations this
is 3 P 2 which is 3 factorial over 3
minus 2 factorial 3 factorial is just 3
times 2 times 1 3 minus 2 is 1 factorial
which is just 1 and you can see we have
3 times 2 which is 6 so if we want to
write these down really quick this is
going to be a B or you could get B and
then a that's considered a different
permutation that's a different outcome
because the order is important
you could get let's see a C C a and what
else you could do C B and you could also
do B C so you can see there's 6
different ways to pick two marbles out
of the 3 now if we were doing
combinations okay let's do the exact
same problem how many ways are there to
choose 2 out of the 3 well that's going
to be
three factorial over three minus 2
factorial 2 factorial okay so if we
simplify this we get 3 2 1 3 minus 2 is
1 factorial which is 1 2 factorial is 2
times 1 and you can see that twos the
ones
okay and we're left with 3 divided by 1
which is 3 so let's go back to the
outcomes here notice a b and b a from a
combination perspective those are the
same two marbles so whether you get a
and B be an A you don't really care you
say well I've got the same two marbles
right so that's just one one outcome
here we've got a and CCN a those are the
same two marbles and C and B B and C
those are the same two marbles so you
can see when you're doing combinations
where the order doesn't matter you're
going to have fewer possibilities fewer
outcomes and you can see here in the
formula this R factorial okay here in
this case 2 factorial what you're doing
because there's two items and you can
have them two different ways you're
dividing out those duplicates okay are
those multiplicities so this is just a
simple example let's get into some other
examples let's do this one here how many
ways can you arrange five books on a
shelf okay where the order is important
so you want to put the books like that
well there's a couple different ways to
do this problem one way to do it is just
to diagram it out like this and you can
say well there's five choices for the
book that I put here right then once I
put that book there there's only four
books left from which to pick from to
put in the second position and then it
goes down from there three to one and if
we multiply all those together we get a
hundred and twenty different
permutations different orderings right
the other way to do this problem is you
could say well out of five books how
many ways can I pick five okay the P
stands for permutations but I just like
to say pick five so out of five total
how many ways can you pick five where
the order matters so if we go to our
formula here the NPR formula we have
five factorial over five minus five
factorial that's five factorial
zero factorial and remember zero
factorial actually equals one that's
just something you'll have to memorize
one factorials one and zero factorial is
one so this just ends up being 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 all divided by 1
which is the same thing we got here 120
so you can see sometimes there's a
couple different ways to approach these
problems let's look at the next one how
many ways can you pick two co-captains
on a team of 20 so visualize you're on a
sports team there's 20 players and you
want to pick two co-captains now let me
ask you a question does the order matter
is there like a head co-captain and like
a assistant co-captain or they the same
in this case they're the same it doesn't
specify any importance as far as the
order is concerned so that tells us that
we're going to be using which one
permutations or combinations
combinations because the order doesn't
matter so what we're going to do is out
of 20 players we're gonna choose two
okay so this is a total we're choosing
two let's use our formula 20 factorial
over 20 minus 2 which is 18 factorial 2
factorial if we expand this out we get
20 times 19 times 18 dot dot dot all the
way down to 1 that's the factorial
represents 18 factorial is 18 times 17
times 16 all the way down to 1 right and
then 2 factorial is just 2 times 1 so
you can see here the 18 17 16 all the
way down to 1 those cancel out 2 factor
is 2 times 1 but that goes into 20 10
times so you can see there's 10 times 9
190 different ways to pick 2 co-captains
an order doesn't matter okay last
problem I hope you're enjoying these
videos if you are subscribe to the
channel and I've got more videos like
these coming you can check out some of
my past videos as well and let's take a
look at the last example here though in
a 50-person race how many ways can you
award gold silver and bronze okay so let
me ask you a question is the order
important yes so the order is important
right because if you switch the
finishers so
else is going to get the gold medal and
somebody else is going to get the silver
medal so the order is important so in
this problem we definitely want to use
permutations
okay NPR and out of the 50 runners or 50
competitors okay out of 50 you're
picking three gold silver and bronze the
first three places right so this is
going to be